Bruce Feldman back here on the Rich
Eisen show part of the Direct TV 4k
college football report once again how
are you Bruce
I'm doing well rich good to be ology so
let's start with let's start I guess
with USC tonight there they're not
having the left tackle that has been
providing protection for Sam Donald all
year long the offensive line is is not
intact tonight Bruce correct
Toula Loeb and Don who's really started
all over the line but he's been you know
one of their best the most experienced
offensive lineman he's not going to go
have an experience on the other side of
line so left and right tackle are going
to be very young remember this one
offensive line that had I think at least
three maybe four guys who went to the
combine last year so they got a lot of
new parts in front of Sam Donald the
receiving corps he has Dante Burnett but
it's still kind of a work in progress
and we see him he has seven
interceptions through the first four
games it's been a lot of inconsistency
with this group and that's not an easy
place they're going to play tonight and
at the coalition that Wazzu hasn't
beaten anybody really of note you know
Boise State's pretty down that was
that's the best win but this is gonna be
an interesting matchup for USC because
it's like I said it's not an easy place
to get to at Washington State especially
when you're under offensive behind his
banged up and then you know I mentioned
how Nebraska and Illinois is again the
4k Ultra HD college football DirecTV
game of the week tonight and Nebraska I
mean is Mike Riley basically playing for
his gig right now every single day yeah
he's in a tough spot the ad Lulu had
hired him Shawn eichorst he was fired a
couple of weeks back and just made some
really bad moves politically in turn I
checked off a lot of folks that didn't
sit well you know they've struggled
often so he can early as a quarterback
as a transfer he's talented and a lot of
NFL people I think we're intrigued by
his skillset but he's thrown a lot of
pics and they've just been really really
inconsistent and the schedule now get
you know after this game if you know
Illinois is probably the weakest team
they have left if they somehow lose this
game these
so much trouble because he still got
three opponents who were top of the
ranked in the top 11 ahead they got to
find a way to play a lot better whereas
Illinois
I mean Lovie Smith is struggle to get it
going they got blown out at UCF a couple
weeks back they had an off week so it's
it it's a must-win game I think really
for both teams here and again that's
tonight at 8 Eastern 5 Pacific on
channel 106 here on DirecTV it's the 4k
game of the week and then you're around
Iowa how in the world are they bouncing
back from that last-second loss to Penn
State at home last week Bruce yeah
that's you know both these teams in this
game you have one with Iowa where it was
the you know crushing loss for state
corn Berkeley did everything up till T
and then the last play they they gave up
a touchdown pass and I think for them
you know it's there's a it's just kind
of hey this is our mo we're gonna be the
tougher team well here they're facing a
team Michigan State that lost the Notre
Dame had a bunch of turnovers a lot of
self-inflicted wounds and coming off
last year where they had you know the
bottom just fell out on their C's and I
think it's get interesting to see how
both these teams are gonna respond to to
going from the unbeaten ranks last week
Bruce Feldman on the sidelines of that
game again for Fox Sports Iowa at
Michigan State Sports Illustrated's
Bruce Feldman also si.com college
football analyst here in our Direct TV
4k college football report so let's talk
about the the the investigation that was
announced a couple of weeks ago a couple
of days ago in the arrests in college
basketball how is that reverberating in
the halls of college football Bruce you
know it's a different kind of animal
because it look let's not kid ourselves
plenty of cheating that goes on in
college football too
but it's just not on the same you know
it's not in the same places in terms of
you know these shoe companies which are
involved in this with a basketball side
they're just not they're just not you
know chasing after these recruits
because there isn't the one and done and
you know man a five star football
recruit but there's no guarantees you
know what they're gonna develop like the
area where I think it's got a lot of
people concerned is you've seen a lot of
ABS who are you know and
bertie you know how how many Pelle how
widespread of the tentacles going to be
reaching into here you know we see an
obviously a Louisville where when Bobby
Petrino becomes your you know for milena
Dean of athletics which is your most
esteemed integrity guy out of your you
know coaches that's a problem you know I
mean you know the Rick Pitino scandal
the latest scandal and then Tom George
the ad there I mean my god you know
that's that looks is about as bad as
it's gonna get from this part of the
scandal but I think this thing is still
unfolding now from what I had heard from
a source last night they thought it
could impact up to forty school Wow
when this thing unfolds and I think it's
it's just getting traction now and so I
think college football people are like
glad it's not us but you know they have
their own problems to deal with when it
comes a lot of these scandals so we are
you say I'm trying to read in between
some of the lines here is Petrino
despite what has been rebuilt there for
him at Louisville could he be looking at
the the departure of the guy who rehired
him and Tom George and say I need to
start looking over the steering wheel
and I think I don't I don't think that
would be the case just because you know
yes he wins football games I'm just not
sure how many other athletic departments
are gonna sign on to work time Bobby
Petrino represent them and all of that
entails but they're you know there's
that's definitely an athletic department
in transition right now and I think that
given you know how much they've upgraded
you know they got into the ACC they've
done a lot of things to kind of get on
better footing and upgraded facilities
there's a lot of positives that guy did
as an ad but just just in terms of the
the optics of hey you hired Bobby
Petrino and then you got you know Pitino
involved in one scandal after how many
salacious things I mean prostitution and
just you know you know the mistress
having an abortion it's just like this
looks like stuff it should be on HBO
scripted TV stuff right a couple more
minutes here with Bruce Feldman and the
DirecTV 4k college football report
the chances of an upset with Virginia
Tech taken on Clemson this weekend that
is a tough place to play rich III would
not be shocked but Foster is a really
really good defensive coordinator he's
got a talented defense with a lot of
experience you know and I think that
they could give Clemson some problems
the thing that's really you know eye
catching about Clemson is they having
nasty defensive line I mean just big
super athletic guys and Josh Jackson is
a redshirt freshman quarterback he's
from Ann Arbor has played really really
well but you know he Clemson is gonna
gonna really challenge him and I think
what you saw Clemson do to Auburn a few
weeks ago 11 sacks got all really after
Jared Stidham I mean if he can avoid the
mistakes I think they have a chance
because you know they're they're very
well coached and like I said that is a
really tough place to play it gets it
gets really loud when when when their
role and I think if we're gonna be up
for this game it's just you know how
well can their young quarterback play
for four quarters against a a really
really talented decoy and I know you've
been very high on Oklahoma State this
year were you shocked by the TCU
beatdown in a way I was rich because our
crew actually did that matchup last year
in Fort Worth and they just absolutely
dominated TCU those via KHOU the other
way was just was just just kind of
really eye-opening to me but you know
what Gary Patterson's was good at
defensive coaches there was in college
football he made some really you know
smart adjustments to how they attack
them and it was it was the first real
test for the Oklahoma State defense and
obviously they failed it miserably
before I let you go we're gonna see our
first October football um coming up
entering October
say Kwan Barclays number one of the
Heisman race correct that kid is dynamic
he's electric there's no actually those
are those are words that I don't even
think do justice what he's been what he
looks like on that field Bruce he looks
like a professional football player out
there yeah my comparison is he has the
elusiveness and the wow factor of red
you Bush in a 230 pound power back you
know he is everything you want in terms
of you know
great character kid great worker he's in
a really good system for it where they
have enough athletes stretching field
downfield and take a little pressure off
them he is the clear number one right
now I would say Baker Mayfield is behind
him because he's played well but right
now it's a two horse race and and but
it's still like he said it's we're just
getting into October a lot changes but
you know he is he has a lot of fun to
watch the country got to see it the
other night yeah man if I'm a family in
the NFL and I need to run him back I'm
just saying how do I get my hands on
this kid how do I do you know what rich
and you think about it I've heard some
people don't like kind of like a little
bit like Ezekiel Elliott with what this
kid is there are no character issues you
know I mean just you talk to people at
Penn State they rave about him his work
ethic you spend any time around him you
become a believer Ranum he checks off
every box he's way bigger than he looks
when you see him in person he was 230
pounds not 210 he's a 4:3 guy he works
his butt off
I mean it's fitting that the
game-winning play he didn't touch it he
did something that you wouldn't see in
the box score he's known the linebacker
in protection that's what I mean that's
what I mean by professional three DS
three down that's that's how you stay on
the field all three downs in the NFL as
you pass protect which is why I think
people might be equated in the Ezekiel
Elliott from the big play ability and
the and the smarts to know what to do on
the field to stay on the field as he has
the eye I don't see honestly nobody gets
a good clean shot on him and you can't
take him down I mean you hit him in the
legs and and it doesn't take him down as
a matter of fact he'll just he might be
thrown off balance but then he gets
perfectly back on balance and gets
another ten yards it's truly I can't
stop raving about him obviously we're
been talking about for three minutes
right now yes two guys here I have a man
across I'm fake one Barclay just about
everybody else who covers how much the
ball has that same man crushed you okay
take care yourself Bruce have a good one
Iowa and Michigan State we'll see you on
the side that's at Bruce Feldman cfb on
Twitter that's the Direct TV 4k college
football report
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
del Mona rap please just if if it's a
memory thing just delete other EPS you
don't need those apps this app the Rich
Eisen show up you need that